Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Emre Göchtas. Ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie.
Bevor wir anfangen, lassen Sie mich bitte zuerst Ihre persönliche Daten notieren.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, bitte geben Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie nach.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Manschred Simon.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachname Buch stabilieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist Manschred M-A-N-F-R-E-D.
E-D, okay.
Und der Familienname ist Simon S-I-M-O-N.
Okay.
Herr Simon, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 74 Jahre alt.
Sie haben starke Hüften.
Ja, ich habe sehr, sehr schlimme Hüften.
Ja, können Sie ein bisschen sprechen mit mir?
Ja, natürlich.
Okay.
Wahnsinnige Bore.
Am 25. April 1948.
Okay. Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, ich wiege noch 89 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,78 m.
78, ja.
Mhm.
Wo wohnen Sie?
Ich wohne in Reine.
Reiner.
Und wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist Dr. Möllers.
Dr. Müllas.
Möllers mit Ö.
Mit Ö.
Okay.
Mhm.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Rentner, ich bin ja schon 74.
Ah, genau.
Was war Ihr Beruf?
Ja, ich bin Busfahrer gewesen.
Und wie sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin serviert mit meiner Frau, ist verstorben.
Ja, es tut mir sehr leid.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe drei erwachsene Töchter.
Gut.
Herr Simon, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, also Sie haben mir schon gemerkt, ich habe solche Furchtbaren Husten.
Und den Husten habe ich eigentlich schon lange.
Aber irgendwie geht es mir nicht gut.
Und jetzt kommt damit einmal beim Husten,
kommt so blutiges Zeug mit raus.
Und ich fühle mich total schlapp und müde.
Und wenn ich also,
das, was ich nach dem Spaziergang,
die Treppe hochgehen will,
oder wenn ich vom Briefkasten komme und die Treppe hochgehen will,
dann kriege ich schon fast keine Luft mehr.
Dann klopft das Herz auch ganz doll.
Dann habe ich das Gefühl, ich komme überhaupt nicht mehr nach oben.
Mhm, ich verstehe.
Sie haben gesagt schon länger, haben Sie Husten.
Ja, dann habe ich schon jahrelang den Husten.
Aber ich habe gedacht, ich rauch halt.
Und dann hustet man halt ein bisschen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und diese, gibt es irgendwelche Ausrufe?
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben einen blutigen Ausruf, ja?
Ja, ja, ja, da kommt jetzt so blutiger Schleim raus, ja.
Seit wann haben Sie bemerkt?
Ja, das ist auch schon ein paar Wochen her.
Ich habe immer gedacht, das geht von alleine wieder weg.
Welche? Okay.
Und Sie haben auch bei Belastung Atemnot?
Ja, also, was weiß ich, wenn ich ein bisschen schneller versuche zu gehen,
weil ich noch die grüne Ampel kriegen will.
Oder wenn ich die Treppe hochlaufen muss.
Oder wenn ich mich bürgen muss beim Bettbeziehen oder sowas,
muss man ja alles alleine machen.
Ja, dann merke ich das mit einmal, dass ich so eine Pause machen muss,
weil es mir gar nicht gut geht.
Haben Sie bemerkt, wann diese Beschwerden aufgetreten sind?
Die Atemnot, ich meine.
Das ist bestimmt schon jetzt ein Viertel, ja, so.
Okay, und drei Monate.
Okay, haben Sie bemerkt, ob Sie Fieber haben?
Ne, habe ich aber auch nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich eigentlich nicht fieberig.
Okay.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Genau, wenn Sie zum Beispiel beim Einatmen oder Ausatmen haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Nein, ich nicht so sehr eher so dieses Gefühl, dass ich gar keine Luft kriege.
Also eher nicht schmerzhaft.
Okay.
Aber natürlich, wenn man so permanent hustet, dann ist man irgendwann so erschöpft, wissen Sie?
So, so, dass man das Gefühl hat, das ist so anstrengend, ne?
Ja, ich verstehe, ja.
Haben Sie Probleme, etwas zu schlucken?
Ne, das eigentlich nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Früher war der gut, aber in letzter Zeit ist er nicht weit her damit.
Da wissen Sie, ich muss mir ja auch alleine etwas kochen.
Schmeckt halt nicht.
Aber ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, ob Sie in der letzten Zeit abgenommen?
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich tüchtig abgenommen.
Ich merke, dass das so die Hosen, ne?
Die Hosen werden weiter.
Und ja, mich wiegt mich ja nicht so oft, ne?
Also, aber jetzt bin ich neulich mal auf der Waage gewesen und da war ich überrascht,
weil ich tatsächlich 6 kg abgenommen habe.
Welche Zeitraum haben Sie 6 kg abgenommen?
Vielleicht so ein halbes Jahr.
Okay.
Haben Sie, laden Sie unter Nachschweiß?
Nachschweiß?
Oder Schweißausbücke?
Ne.
Nachschwörter, Tagsüber?
Ne, sowas habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, also eigentlich sonst.
Ich habe natürlich so ein paar Vorerkrankungen,
was man so hat, ne?
Der Blutdruck ist höher und dann habe ich eine vergrößerte Prostata
und ich bin in einer Bandscheibe operiert
und jetzt habe ich wieder ein Bandscheibenvorfall,
aber das will ich nicht mehr operieren lassen in meinem Alter.
Also Bluthochdruck und Prostatavergrößerung,
haben Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, wie gesagt, dieser Bandscheibenvorfall,
der jetzt noch mal da ist, den gibt es noch
und dann habe ich tatsächlich auch einen grauen Starr.
Grauen Starr, okay.
Haben Sie dagegen operiert?
Ne, ich will da keine Operation.
Bist du in meinem Alter, da muss man nicht mehr so viel anstellen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Okay, Herr Simon, gibt es in Ihrer Familie
schwere oder wichtige Erkrankungen?
Ja, also meine Eltern sind bei halt nicht so furchtbar alt geworden.
Meine Mutter ist an Brustkrebs gestorben
und mein Vater hatte einen Herz entfragt.
Auch gestorben?
Die sind beide schon, die sind ja schon ewig lange her.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ne, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Die Töchter, da weiß ich nichts,
dass da irgendjemand krank ist.
Ne, die sind glaube ich alle fit, ja.
Okay, das freut mich.
Haben Sie Probleme ein oder durchzuschlafen?
Ja, wegen der Prostata muss ich halt nachts ein paar Mal raus.
Da schläft man nicht so gut durch.
Und ja, manchmal muss ich auch wegen des Hustens einfach aufstehen.
Und also mit der Nachtruhe ist es nicht so weit her.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Ja, bei Wasserlassen habe ich ja gesagt,
dass ich nachts immer raus muss auf die Toilette.
Und tagsüber, naja, muss man auch zwischen durch.
Aber mit dem Stuhlgang ist eigentlich nichts Besonderes.
Gibt es etwas, was Sie sie nicht belastet?
Nein, nein, nein. Also, hat mich mit dem allen so abgefunden, wie es ist.
Okay, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme irgendwas wegen der Prostata.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das Medikament heißt,
aber da muss ich etwas einnehmen.
Und dann habe ich noch Augen.
Ich habe noch Augen, ich habe noch Augen.
Und dann habe ich noch Augen tropfen für beide Augen.
Und dann habe ich noch ein Medikament, das heißt Konkor 50.
Da muss ich morgens eine nehmen.
Konkor 50.
Okay.
Seit wann oder rufen Sie?
Jetzt nicht mehr, früher habe ich richtig, richtig viel geraucht.
Aber jetzt rauche ich nur noch, seit 10 Jahren rauche ich nur noch Pfeife.
Aber vorher habe ich 40 Jahre lang wirklich heftig geraucht.
Da habe ich anderthalb Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Ein, ein Päckchen.
Ein, ein halb.
Ein, okay.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol kann man das nicht nennen.
Also ich trinke am Tag eine Flasche Bier.
Sonst eigentlich nix.
Okay.
Seit wann trinken Sie?
Ja, wann fängt man an, Bier zu trinken.
Mit 16 oder so, 17.
Ja.
Aber dass ich das jetzt jeden Tag trinke, seit ich erwachsen bin.
Früher als Busfahrer, nach Feierabend, hat man sich halt sein Bier gegönnt.
Genau, genau.
Und das habe ich bald behalten.
Ist bei Ihnen Allergien bekannt?
Ja, ich vertrag tatsächlich kein Jod.
Und dann habe ich mal gegen Schmerzen,
Noralgin bekommen.
Und das habe ich auch gar nicht vertragen.
Wie äußert es diese Allergien?
Ja, ich kriege dann so einen Ausschlag, der ganz schrecklich juckt.
Beide?
Bei beiden ja.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Simon.
Und ja, unsere Kollegen.
Okay.
Jetzt meinerseits habe ich die wichtigste Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen?
Ja, ich frage mich natürlich, was, was jetzt dahinter steckt und
wie ich wieder auf die Beine komme.
Aber wissen Sie, ich will mich auf keinen Fall operieren lassen.
Also da habe ich keine Lust mehr drauf.
Die Bandscheibe lasse ich so und mit den Augen, das lasse ich auch nicht
machen.
Und mit dem Husten jetzt, also das muss irgendwie,
können Sie mir irgendwelche guten Tabletten geben,
dass das wieder besser wird?
Ja, wir möchten auch Sie operieren.
Aber erst mal müssen wir die richtige Diagnose feststellen.
Deswegen sollten Sie heute bei uns bleiben, damit wir die weitere
Untersuchungen durchführen können.
Was wird denn da gemacht?
Ja, erst mal ich würde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Danach, danach ich würde Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ich schicke Sie
Röntgen.
Zum Röntgen, okay.
Zum Röntgen, genau.
Nach der Röntgen-Untersuchung würde ich ein Ultraschall
bei Ihnen durchführen.
Danach, nach der Ergebnisse besprechen wir nochmal, okay?
Ja, wie lange dauert das denn alles?
Ja, in einem Tag können wir alle Untersuchungen schaffen,
aber wir müssen die Ergebnisse ein bisschen warten.
Wir müssen auf die Ergebnisse ein bisschen warten.
Besonders die Blutabnahme, Blutergebnisse kann ein bisschen
dauern.
Ein paar Stunden vielleicht.
Ja, nach der Ergebnisse, wenn ich Ergebnisse bekomme,
gebe ich Ihnen Bescheid.
Dann können wir nochmal sprechen, wie das weitergeht, okay?
Ja, ja, ja, okay, gut.
Okay, und jetzt können Sie in Untersuchungsthema gehen.
Ja, ich komme gleich.
Ja, super, okay, dann gehe ich da mal rüber.
Okay.
Und unser Kollegen hat ein paar Fragen.
Haben Sie Heiserkeit?
Heiserkeit habe ich nicht, nein.
Und dort drinnen?
Auch nicht.
Okay.
Und fühlen Sie sich endg?
Haben Sie enge Gefühle?
Ja, enge Gefühle.
Genau.
Enge Gefühle, nee, enge Gefühle würde ich das nicht nennen.
Das ist.
Danke, Husten.
Und danach zum Beispiel ein enge Gefühl in der Brust.
Ja, so diese Luftnoten, da man das als engen Gefühl kann man
vielleicht so bezeichnen, ja.
Ist also jetzt nicht explizit so beschrieben,
aber vielleicht kann man das so gut bezeichnen, ja.
Okay.
Takipno im anem neze Pragn oder?
Ja, sie hat bei Belastung Atemnot.
Takipno, takipno, Frekans.
Ach, das ist zu schnell Atme.
Ja, schnell Atme.
Ja, nee, eher so dieses Gefühl, dass ich nix reinkriege.
Takipar, du.
So, ne?
Herzrasen.
Ja, Herzrasen, ja.
Wie viele Kissen benutzen Sie zum Schlafen?
Wie viele Kissen zum Schlafen?
Ja, ich habe jetzt schon zwei Kissen übereinander.
Ich habe mir das von meiner Frau gewohnt,
die ist ja nicht mehr da.
Sie müssen oft nach Toilette gehen.
Ja, zwei bis drei Mal jede Nacht, ja.
Wegen der Prostata, ne?
Ich habe andere Fragen.
Bei der ersten Anemne, der Hustete der Patient laut,
wir sollten, wir als Arzt, hier reagieren.
Ich schaue mir zum Beispiel selbst Ihre Sauerstoff-Septigung an
und zum Beispiel.
Also, solange der nicht...
Oder müssen wir oder nicht?
Also, ich würde, ich würde maximal,
bei dieser, das ist ja dauernd ja nicht lange,
das Gespräch, ich würde maximal Schluckwasser anbieten,
brauchen Sie etwas zum Trinken, ne?
Dass der, dass der auch für zu husten.
Ich habe ja nicht die ganze Zeit durchgerustet,
weil ich das selber nicht mehr konnte, ja.
Wenn ich der echte Patient wäre,
hätte ich wahrscheinlich die ganze Zeit durchgerustet, ja.
Aber Sie sind sehr gute Schauspieler.
Ja, aber ich kann das nicht durchziehen.
Ich schaff das nicht, das ganze Gespräch über zu husten, ne?
Das war nur am Anfang als kleines Signal, sozusagen.
Wer ist zum Beispiel ein Wasser,
möchten Sie ein Wasser trinken?
Ja, das fände ich, das fände ich jetzt okay.
Ich würde jetzt nicht schon gleich sagen,
wir müssen Sauerstoff-Septigung messen,
brauchen Sie Sauerstoff oder so,
wenn der nicht da sitzt und nach Luft schnappt, ja.
Also, ich denke mal, solange der,
solange der nur hustet, ne?
Ja.
Ja, sein Dreck da hoch hustet, ne?
Wie Sie fragen, gefragt hat,
sind Sie in letzter Zeit deswegen im Krankenhaus gewesen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein, der ist ja, das ist ja ein eher ignoranter Patient.
Der hat das ja seit vier Jahren, hat er husten
und seit Monaten hat er blutigen Auswurf.
Ja.
Er ist ein Arzt, ne?
Und, ja, so, der war noch nicht vorher eben voran, das.
Okay.
Noch Fragen oder soll ich die Patientin abstimmen, am Anfang?
Ich weiß nicht, ob noch jemand sonst Fragen hat.
Sieht nicht so aus.
Ja, dann starten wir.
Okay, guten Tag Frau Oberärztin.
Ja, schönen guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit?
Ja, natürlich.
Wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Okay, es geht um Herr Manfred Simon,
ist 74-jähriger Patient
und er hat ungefähr seit,
er klagt über husten seit vier, vier Jahre
und er fühlt sich müde
und als weiterer,
diese husten ist, hat blutiger Sputun.
Seit wann?
Seit vier Monaten.
Na toll.
Ja, vier Monate.
Ja.
Und als weiterer Beschwerden nennt er,
und seit drei Monaten
und er hat in der letzten sechs Monaten 6 kg abgenommen.
Ja, in der Vorerkrankungen gibt es arteriale Hypertonie
pro Statipeplasie,
arteriale Hypertonie pro Statipeplasie,
habe ich die und Diskusprolaps vor
und Graustafo, Katarakt vor.
Ja, genau.
Und in der Familienanamnese liegt mutterlicherseits
Mama Katzinom
und vaterlicherseits Myokartinfarkt.
In der vegetative Anamnese klagt er
über Nocturie
und deswegen hat sie Parasomnie.
Hat ja Parasomnie
und er nimmt ein paar Medikamente gegen Prostata
und nimmt Avonthrop, Prostata und Konko ein,
aber die Medikamente gegen Prostata
weiß ja die Name von, gegen Prostata,
die Name, den Namen des Medikaments
wegen der Prostata kennt er nicht.
Genau.
Und er benutzt auch einen Augentropfen.
Er raucht, er hat 4 Jahre lang
1,5 Päckchen geraucht,
aber seit 10 Jahren ist er nicht raucher
und er trinkt seit jahrelang
1 Flasche Bier.
Pro Tag.
Ja, okay.
Genau.
Er ist allergisch gegen Jod und Novalgin.
Und nach den bisherigen Angaben
gehe ich von Lungenkrebs
aus.
Dafür sprechen die Dyspne
und Gewichtverlust
und blutige Sputum
und Russen.
Und auch als Risikofaktoren
gibt in Familie
Mama Karzinom,
Mutter ist es.
Und die Nikotinkonsum.
Was wären Differenzialdiagnosen?
Differenzialdiagnose, ich komme zum Beispiel
Laring-Karzinom
und ein Herzinsuffizienz
im Betrag.
Ja, haben wir noch ein paar Ideen,
was uns noch vielleicht sein könnte?
Denken Sie noch mal in der Lunge ein bisschen rum.
Er hat die
ohne Schmerzen,
sprechen gegen Ployritis.
Deswegen, das kann
sein.
Er hätte wahrscheinlich auch eine Pneumonie,
das ist schon richtig.
Aber so danach sollten wir noch gucken,
auf alle Fälle.
Was könnte es noch sein?
Ich denke eher an eine Infektionskrankheit.
COPD.
Oder Infektionen, denken Sie mal.
Ja, ist zwar so gut wie ausgerottet,
aber gibt es doch immer noch mal wieder.
Ja, okay.
Was machen Sie denn mit dem,
jetzt von der Diagnostik?
Erstmal, natürlich würde ich
den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie da besonders?
Für diese Patienten,
für diese Patienten ist Auskultation
sehr wichtig.
Erstmal,
wir können die Stridor hören.
Und die Auskultation
zeigt auch
vielleicht die
Rastlgeräusche.
Ja, oder die Infektration, sowas.
Ja, Infektrationen.
Ja, und
noch körperliche Untersuchungen
können wir auch percutieren.
Ja, und was können Sie noch machen?
Ja, die Palfation.
Wir müssen die Lämpfknoten
überkontrollieren, ob es
pergrößert oder nicht.
Genau.
Und dann, ich würde auch
diese Patienten
Röntgen veranlassen.
Okay.
Hat er irgendwas gesagt,
wann er zuletzt mal geräunigt worden ist?
Die Lunge?
Nein, habe ich nicht gefragt.
Röntgen können wir die
Raumförderung vielleicht
zeigen.
Das Röntgen können wir uns auch zeigen.
Wenn wir es nicht sehen können,
was könnte man dann noch machen?
Wir können natürlich ein Ultraschall durchführen
oder gegebenenfalls
wir können auch eine City veranlassen.
Genau.
Was machen Sie denn labortechnisch?
Als Labor
können wir
erst mal Blut abnehmen
und ein Sputumkultur schicken.
Ja, gut.
Und was gucken wir,
wann Blut?
Wir haben die Erzündungparameter
und die
großes, kleines Blutbild
auch großes Blutbild
können wir machen.
Erst mal, die sind genug, aber
Ja, genau.
Ja, gut.
Was wäre dann,
eine Verschatterung sehen in der Lunge
oder eine
Raumförderung, was wäre dann der nächste Schritt?
Nächste Schritt,
dann müssen wir ein Probe entnehmen,
Biopsy.
Und wie machen wir das?
Ja, okay.
Und was würden Sie dann,
wenn wir da fündig geworden sind,
wenn wir da tatsächlich entdecken,
da ist ein Tumor geschehen,
wie wäre dann das weitere Vorgehen,
auch hinsichtlich der Diagnostik noch?
Um die richtige Diagnose feststellen
oder nach der...
Wenn wir feststellen, der hat tatsächlich
einen Schmutz,
dann mussten wir dann auf alle Fälle noch
anschließen.
Der hat das Lungenkarzinom ja wahrscheinlich nicht
erst seit Vorgastan.
Das ist ja relativ weit fortgeschritten.
Genau.
Das heißt, wenn das Fortgeschrittener ist,
dann können wir nicht diese Patienten operieren.
Deswegen können wir die
auf alle Fälle noch auf alle Fälle noch auf alle Fälle
und auf alle Fälle noch auf alle Fälle.
Und wonach müssen wir aber auch noch gucken,
wenn wir einen positiven Befund kriegen
im Sinne von Karzinomenerkrankungen?
Wonach müssen wir dann nochmal schauen?
Die Metastasen, meine ich.
Ja, genau.
Also CT-Hofen?
Mit Kontrastmitteln.
Besonders die Rücken und Gehirn.
Kopf und...
Aber so eine ganze Körper machen.
Eigentlich am besten eine ganze Körper
oder eine Tomografie.
Damit man da auf Tomose hochgehen kann.
Wunderbar.
Ja, dann bin ich ja gespannt,
was die für Befunde rausbekommen.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden bei Herrn Simon.
Ja.
Dann bin ich ja mal gespannt, was aus dem wird.
Das war, würde ich sagen,
eine sehr schöne,
sowohl Ananäse als auch Darsteller.
Aber dieser als auch Darstellung.
Nur in einer Hinsicht
war es echt
bei den Noxen.
Der hat nicht vier Jahre lang Zigaretten geraucht.
40.
Aber ich fiel ja genau.
Aber ne, 40 Jahre.
Der hat also, wie viel, der hat 60 Päck hier auf dem Buckel.
Genau.
Und jetzt raucht er seit zehn Jahren Pfeife.
Weil Zigaretten hat man ja wenigstens noch den Filter.
Aber bei der Pfeife,
das gilt ja als extrem
krebserregend.
Und das hat die Oberärztin
auch nicht erfahren, dass der Pfeife raucht.
Ja.
Und das ist natürlich irgendwo das ganz klare
und das ist auch in welche Richtung das geht.
Oder woher es kommt.
Ja.
Und sonst würde ich aber sagen, top.
Was meinen Sie?
Wie kann man den Patienten erklären?
Die rauchen aufhören.
Überkrebs.
Ach so, ja.
Also gerade bei diesen
ist das jetzt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schwierig,
weil der nicht so ganz schlau ist.
Und weil er das auch so lange verschleppt hat.
Ob das weiß man nicht so genau.
Will er es nicht wissen?
Weil er es nicht wahrhaben will.
Ja.
Das gibt es ja auch.
Das Leute einfach nicht zum Arzt gehen, weil sie sagen, ich will das nicht hören.
Ich mache die Augen zu und dann passiert schon nichts.
Ja, so Vogelstraußpolitik.
Dass man den Kopf in den Sand steckt.
Oder aber dass er tatsächlich geglaubt hat.
Das ist ja nur ein bisschen Husten.
Das wird schon nicht so schlimm sein.
Ja.
Und in beiden Fällen ist das natürlich schwierig.
Jemandem zu erklären.
Ja, wir müssen schon davon ausgehen.
Dass es eine ernst zu nehmen, der Erkrankung ist.
Und ich glaube.
Jetzt in dem Fall, das ist ein alleinstehender Mann.
Und er hat ja schon signalisiert.
Er will sich.
Wegen nichts operieren lassen.
Ja, wegen der Augen nicht und wegen der Bandscheibe nicht.
Und sowieso alles.
Ich bin doch ewe alt und.
Ich bin ja nicht mehr.
Da brauche ich auch keine OP.
Und da muss man tatsächlich.
Dann ja so ein bisschen, bisschen gucken, wie die Situation ist.
Ja.
Dass man sagt.
Ja, was würdest du sagen?
Sag mal.
Das schwierig.
Ja.
Ich habe jetzt Ihre Ergebnisse.
Und so.
Bei Ihrem Untersuchung.
Ich spreche mir darüber in der Indur.
Okay.
Und ja jetzt leider.
Muss ich mit Ihnen die Diagnose mitteilen.
Das ist.
Das ist sehr scharf.
Scharf Einleitung.
Ja, man kann sagen.
Leider haben wir was gefunden, was nicht so gut aussieht.
Oder so.
Das ist.
Ich habe keine guten Neuigkeiten für Sie oder so.
Was könnte man sagen?
Als Einleitung.
Leider habe ich keine.
Hab ich keine gute Nachricht für Sie.
Und.
Das ist eine.
Eine.
Patologie.
In der Probe.
In der Probe haben wir festgestellt,
dass Sie ein Lungen Krebs.
Lungen Krebs haben.
Aber erst mal.
Bitte.
Erst mal.
Wollen Sie ruhig bleiben?
Das ist nicht.
Das.
Krankheit zu behandeln, deswegen und ja. Ja, ist doch super. Ja, ja. Das ist ja so als erste
Information. Also das erste ist tatsächlich, dass man sagt, ja, ich habe keine guten
Nachrichten für Sie, das kann nicht eine sehr schöne Geschichte, so, ne? Und ich würde
doch nicht mal sagen, in der Pathologie haben wir was gefunden, sondern in der
Gewebeuntersuchung, also auch wieder deutsche Sprache, in der Untersuchung des
Gewebes haben wir festgestellt, dass da etwas wächst in ihrer Lunge, was da
nicht hingehört. Das ist ein bösartiger Tumor, wir sagen auch Lungenkrebs
dazu und jetzt müssen wir zusammen besprechen, was wir dagegen unternehmen. Wir
können dagegen ganz viel tun, aber wir brauchen Sie natürlich an unserer Seite,
dass Sie uns unterstützen bei der Therapie und dass Sie mit uns gegen Ihre
Krankheit angehen, so diese Geschichte. Brauchst dich den Patienten mit ins
Boot holen, dass er, dass er selber, ja, dass seine aktive
Mitarbeit auch erforderlich ist, dass man kann ja ihm nicht so eine
invasive Therapie so überstülten, nach dem Motto, das machen wir jetzt, sondern
dass man eben sagt, wir haben Möglichkeit, in was dagegen zu tun.
Das setzt aber voraus, dass Sie da bereit sind dazu und dass Sie uns
unterstützen. Denke mal, das wäre so ein ganz guter Weg. Und dann muss man halt
auch immer wieder gucken, wie der reagiert, ob der jetzt sagt, ich will immer noch
nichts wissen, ja, ich gehe jetzt nach Hause, ich will das nichts weiter sehen,
oder ob der sagt, ich will, wenn Sie meinen, dass das wirklich was hilft,
dann, was kann man denn tun? Aber operieren lasse ich mich nicht. Ja, so, das wäre
ja so denkbar, nach dem Motto, ich schlug Tabletten und ja, wenn das hilft, ist
gut, aber ich lasse mich nicht operieren, das wäre so denkbar. Oder wenn es jetzt
vom Ergebnis so ist, dass man sagt, ja, die OP wäre aber das Mittel der Wahl,
überlegen Sie doch nochmal, Sie können sich damit tatsächlich noch ein paar
Jahre guter Lebensqualität sichern oder so. Kann man alles vorsichtig
so formulieren. War das jetzt ungefähr ein bisschen hilfreich?
Ja, ja. Ist dieser Tumor, was ist er? Ja, Patient, macht fragt, ist dieser Tumor vollständig
heilbar? Ach so, ja, okay. Da muss man, glaube ich, ehrlich sein. Da muss man
ehrlich sein und sagen, ob das vollständig klappt, wissen wir nicht,
wir können den aber auf alle Fälle eindämmen oder ja, das, ich glaube,
da hilft nichts als Ehrlichkeit. Ja, dass man sagt, erfahrungsgemäß kann man
diese Art von Tumor vollständig behandeln. Wenn es aber so ist, dass man sagt,
hm, wir können versuchen, ob wir ihn ganz zur Ruhe bekommen mit diesen
Methoden können, wenn nicht versprechen. Und dann muss man natürlich auch
ehrlicherweise sagen, wie die, wie die Filialisierung ist. Ja, also, hm, wir haben
in ihren Lymphknoten entdeckt, dass da auch was ist, was auch eine weitere
Behandlung benötigt oder im CT haben wir festgestellt, dass der Tumor
einfach schon gestreut hat. Auch dagegen müssten wir etwas unternehmen. Ja, aber
das hängt natürlich auch immer total vom Befund ab, wie der jetzt ist. Aber
sicherlich ist Ehrlichkeit das, was dem Patienten zusteht. Ja, wenn der nicht
komplett, was weiß ich, Banane ist und sagt, also, ich will überhaupt nichts
wissen oder so, ja. Aber, äh, so, Ehrlichkeit ist wichtig, aber halt schonende,
schonende Formulierung, ja, dass man nicht mit der Tür ins Haus, ja, und tschach,
Sie haben Krebs, ne? So, das geht natürlich nicht, ist ja logisch klar, macht ja
keiner, ne? Aber, ähm, so würde ich, so, glaube ich, es ist ein vernünftiges
Vorgehen, was auch so unter Kollegen sicherlich akzeptiert wird. Und ich meine,
das ist ja auch in, in keiner Sprache der Welt anders oder in keinem, in keinem Land
der Welt anders. Es gibt immer den Dialog, gerade bei einer solchen Diagnose.
Es gibt immer den Dialog und es gibt immer diese Notwendigkeit, ähm,
praktisch die Zusammenarbeit mit dem Patienten zu, ähm, zu
diskutieren, sozusagen. Das wird in der Türkei nicht anders gemacht, denke ich,
als, als in Amerika oder, oder in Frankreich oder in Deutschland, ja.
Da ist man sich bestimmt einig.
Okay. Okay. Ja, also für mich war das wirklich eine sehr, sehr perfekte
Vorstellung, Patienten, äh, Anamnese und, und auch Vorstellung. Und, ähm, ich würde sagen,
du musst dir keinen Kopf um die Prüfung machen.
Wirklich nicht, also, ne? Und bis in vier Wochen, oder sind fast acht Wochen,
ja, ne? Vergiss du das auch nicht.
Okay, danke schön.
Alles klar. Gut. So, äh, sind jetzt...